specidids are colorless but as you can
see here they sometimes take on a green
coloring that's not their own pigments
though they take on The Verdant Hue
thanks to algae that have either taken
up residence as a symbiont or that have
had The Misfortune to be eaten in some
cases you can also see bright shimmering
lights glowing from within some of those
are crystalline parts of the organism
While others are sugars that refract
beautifully under our microscope's light
to hunt down their food specidids rely
on the toxics lining their mouths to
immobilize their prey and from there
some species will swallow their meals
whole While others will use chemicals
released by their toxics to mash their
meals up outside their body like a
little protest smoothie that they can
just slurp up